entre les attaques les pompiers de
Kerson sillonnent la ville pour mettre
fin aux incendies et secourir les civils
devant ce qui reste de cette maison
cette ukrainienne pleure son fils tué au
petit matin par un bombardement russe
n'allait pas je voulais qu'il se lève et
qu'il quitte la maison mais il ne l'a
pas fait maintenant nos vies sont
détruites
dans ses mains le passeport de son fils
sortit des décombres elle en aura besoin
pour récupérer sa dépouille et
l'enterrer cette maternité a été ciblée
pas de victimes mais des soignants
terrorisés
l'obstétricien a attrapé un nouveau-né
qui se trouvait encore dans la salle
d'accouchement
et à peine sorti de là les vitres ont
volé en éclat
ce nouveau quotidien sous les missiles
contraste avec les scènes de liesse du
mois dernier quand les troupes
ukrainiennes avaient repris la ville de
Kerson après huit mois d'occupation
russe booter hors de cette ville
stratégique considérée comme la porte
d'entrée vers la Crimée les Russes la
bombarde à présent depuis leur position
à l'est du fleuve Nièvre
depuis ce week-end plusieurs centaines
de civils Ukrainiens se résolvent à
quitter leur ville créant des bouchons à
la sortie de Carson
en pensant que ça passerait
mes voisins et celle de mon père ont été
touchées on a pris peur ce qui reste
prennent chaque jour plus de risques les
frappes tu au hasard comme cette
secouriste bénévole touchée à quelques
mètres seulement de l'abri de la
Croix-Rouge ou la tendait son fils de 12
ans à la gare les autorités ukrainiennes
ont affrété d'être un spéciaux et
encourage les habitants à partir